I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense when I look back and I went to
college and I had sort of always left
health and nutrition and would read
these diet books and played soccer and
was a captain in my soccer team in ASB
super involved like loved my friends
didn't really have a serious boyfriend
until college but I like would go to the
dances and have fun and had a lot of
confidence and I would read the diet
books for the science and I would maybe
do them just to try them out for a
couple of days that never lasted
long-term but it never made me feel bad
about myself when it wouldn't work but
then I dated someone who being a serial
monogamist my parents have been married
for over 40 years like I was being
cheated on without knowing it he's you
know and and athlete a good-looking guy
and it was the first time my confidence
took a real hit and so I started to read
these diet books and sort of really
manifested in me like needing to change
my body right I must not be pretty and
pretty Anatomy and skinny enough good
enough yeah which is the first time I
ever felt that way and so I started to
read these diet books and then I really
started to do it and then when it would
fail because ultimately like I'm a
college kid eating in college cafeteria
or I'm out with friends and I'm wanting
to like really celebrate life and be
this positive person if I had always
been my confidence took major hits and
I'd be like oh I need to and what I felt
was like I talked about the pendulum
ball and you said like balance doesn't
exist it's like this thing where people
think they're gonna be perfect and their
ball is gonna stop and it's not like
it's always gonna be bouncing it's like
homeostasis it's even your blood Sugar's
going up and down and up and down up and
down always its contents never just
solids like steady state and that's how
we are emotionally - and so I'm thinking
about this like light flow and what
ended up happening was I was like doing
these diets trying to do them and then I
was swinging back to like going to Cabo
on spring break with all my friends and
you know and feeling out of control and
not to the point where I'm like oh I'm
binge drinking but I would where I was
like eating all the chips and guac you
know and feeling worse about myself and
so what I was finding I was like all of
these diets do
or make you feel like junk about
yourself and your body and it was
killing my confidence to do the regular
things that I would do like you know be
in a role in my sorority or like playing
on my soccer team or be with my friends
and how was food affecting my confidence
in this way like how I can control all
of my life but I can control up my food
choices I'm I can't not eat that
chocolate I can't not Wyatt why is this
so you know well one it's like human
nature to eat and it also is also
necessary it's necessary it's our first
coping mechanism but the more I tried to
control it the more my pendulum ball
went like this well cause it's a
polarity right so go play or you're over
here on the restriction side the more
you usually fall into the the binge side
of things and so if you can just stay
closer to the middle it doesn't swing so
far and you feel more comfortable in
control which is what it just feels like
you know so authentic to you that you're
you know your program revolves around
this sustainability and ability to
control those triggers yeah you know and
and it's what I needed it's really what
I needed I need it and so I stopped
going to try to do other people's things
and I started looking at these books
differently you know I got out of that
bad relationship I turned back you know
I really came back to myself gave you
the confidence I mean it's kind of a
side question but I you know a lot of
the things that I that I like asking
people about on the show or just certain
things that they've experienced that are
emotional that helps them transition
like you were in this yo-yo of lacking
confidence and then trying to get
confidence in these other ways to you
know impress somebody and you know
eventually you left and so what gave you
that kind of confidence
well it's interesting if sort of would
have to we'd have to go late into the
layers but you know I was raised in a
family where the person that you're with
physically emotionally and sexually is
the person that you marry hmm and so
being that that relationship was my
first real relationship and something I
felt like this
Nate need to hold on to it and to make
it work and honestly I just hit rock
bottom it was like embarrassing when I
would find out that this was happening
it's nothing that I would ever stand for
for my friends yeah like I didn't
understand who I was I didn't feel
anywhere near close to myself because if
it was my friend I would have been like
what the hell are you doing isn't that
in Jesse yeah and like not a reason
you're like oh I'm gonna like we say it
out loud and they're like what would my
oh my friend would say leave [ __ ] yeah
everyone would say leave you know and it
just got embarrassing enough and uhm and
to the point where I I was yeah
I was done and I needed to move on and I
think people just hit rock bottom and
something like that and based on you
know I am thankful for the confidence
that my parents instilled in me in a
young age and that sports instilled in
me and like my friends because I think
that time line was shorter than because
of those factors and I feel bad when
people don't have a little bit of that
foundation wherever they get it to be
able to look at someone who's not
treating you right and say I'm out and I
deserve better and that's sort of you
know I just hit that breaking point and
was like you know what I might
disappoint my parents for not you know
being with this person that I was with
for the first time and marrying that
person but this person isn't right for
me and it's not what they want for me
anyways and I'm gonna own that and go
back to being myself and taking care of
myself first and then we'll um you know
see who I meet
you